with over 1.6 billion active users
that's billion with a b
using facebook right now do you think
that organic traffic is dead
well i have my friend rachel miller on
the podcast today who teaches
thousands of entrepreneurs just like you
how to get organic reach
in the millions of views using this
strategy that she's sharing with you
today
on the podcast
welcome to the think marketing podcast
the number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
i'm heather torres and i'm sean cannell
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening
welcome this show is dedicated to
helping you learn how to get your
content noticed and the latest money
making strategies working right now
online so whether you want to grow your
youtube channel
or you want to maximize video across all
of social media
this podcast is for you rachel thank you
so much for joining
us today on the think marketing podcast
i am so excited to dive into your
expertise
in all things facebook before this
podcast you and i were just having a
conversation about you getting over 60
million views or reach on
facebook i am so excited to bring you as
the expert
to the think marketing show and um first
off can you just tell everyone just a
little bit about who you are
and how you got to where you are today
my first job ever guys was
well like my first job out of college
was actually convincing people not to
cancel their cell phone service
so i made eight dollars and fifty cents
an hour and
i was telling people not to cancel their
cell phone service and i actually loved
that job until my husband
had us move i would have like stayed
there for forever because it was so much
fun
talking on the phone all day and making
people happy when they were mad it was
really like it was a game like they're
coming on angry and i'm changing their
opinions this is awesome i'm having so
much fun
i talk all day this is awesome um
anyways
i'm glad that i didn't can't work at a
call center for the rest of my life
um but i left that and i had a teaching
degree and i moved to texas
and i started teaching for three four
years as an economics teacher
teaching 12th graders and if you can
teach 12th graders you can teach anybody
because 12th graders think they're done
and they think they know more than you
and if you can convince them that the
it's important to learn this whatever
obscure economic fact
they need to learn to pass whatever test
then uh you can teach anybody anything
and so i'm grateful for that opportunity
and then i
got pregnant and i which i wanted to get
pregnant that one was planned
but my second one that i got pregnant
while i was on maternity leave that one
was not planned
so i had to quit teaching because in
texas rural texas they don't pay enough
for two kids and daycare at infant
prices it's so that's that was a little
disappointing i was disappointed at the
time
i was disappointed that i had to stop my
teaching but looking back it was the
biggest gift i'd ever had
so any of your listeners that are here
students right now and they're at a spot
where they feel like
the worst things have happened to them
and they're stuck and they're just
looking for their next step
up you are in the best place because
everything is up and you're here getting
education and
um heather sean they're here holding
your hands they're kicking you in the
pants they're pushing you up that ladder
you're gonna get there just like i did
so i have no experience i'm not special
i don't have any training i don't i
don't have anything other than a love of
people
and some gumption because i had enough i
had only up right
there's nothing but up so i started my
first website
um i grew it to 10 million page views a
month um i
started my second website grew that to 2
million 2.5 i think it's
our highest point that we got a million
pages a month i started two more
websites screw them
and then i was like i think i've got a
system because i'm getting them to kind
of
take off kind of quick and i asked
people do you want me to teach you
this system so first off back up a
second i collected an audience about 100
people
and said do you want me to show you this
so i had to collect those hundred people
first so i collected them
put them into friend interest list first
and then into a facebook group
said do you want me to teach you xyz and
they all said
heck yes and i had 47 of them
purchased my my product is beta um in a
24-hour period
so we were off to the races and um it
was interesting though because i thought
i was going to teach them about
profitable blogging that's not actually
what they wanted
they wanted how'd you drive that traffic
to that blog
by the way facebook so um so i ended up
teaching a facebook
course and as i started teaching people
they're like well tell us more about
this part of facebook
so next thing you know um my students
are having this insane results on
facebook and that's that's where i am
today
and we we keep it simple like when it
started i had
who wants this one product that's all i
had
i one product and then one product on
the back end
as an upsell and then as i grew i and
added three entry points to my funnel so
wow
to me i can already i can feel your
heart in what you're doing
i can feel the purpose in what you're
doing and i think one of the things that
i love so much when you and i connected
gosh i don't know maybe two years ago
i'm trying to think of how long ago it
was we met at a conference which
i think is so powerful to be able to
connect with other people at conferences
and one of the things that i just loved
so much was how
you were really all like stake in the
ground
on organic content meaning like this
isn't paid for content and i think a lot
of business owners come into the online
space
feeling like well one i don't know what
to post i don't know what i should be
posting and two
i don't really have the budget to be
making ads and running facebook things
and
you know one of the things that i i
really value about what you teach to
your audience is
the idea of organic content and so
let's go ahead and tee up you have the
question that comes in all the time
what content should i be posting and i
want i'm taking notes right now to think
marketing podcast because
rachel is the expert in this she she
teaches people and we're going to share
a story here today on the podcast about
one of your
uh one of your um members in your
community
and just the crazy results that they're
getting but the number one question that
everyone's asking right now rachel
is what content right now should i be
posting
on facebook yes i totally love
helping people create that content and
put it out there and i want you know you
don't need to spend a ton of time to
create it
i like to think of it like a stack of
pancakes if you create just one type of
content
at least for facebook you're gonna get
one type of engagement when you get one
type of engagement you're gonna find
that your
your content is gonna have a hard time
snowballing because facebook looks at
the way people interact and says they
want all of the engagements
they want all of the likes the hearts
the shares
they want all of the tags all of the
comments back and forth
all of the stopping and scrolling and
watching the video and then clicking
through and watch
party to watch the next video and the
next they want all of it right they want
people hooked on facebook so what do we
do
to get people hooked on our content so
facebook shows it to more and more
people we think
like facebook how does what does
facebook want from the content what does
our reader want from the content
and then we give it to them so i think
like a stack of pancakes and if you're
watching i don't know if there's a video
of this but i'm like literally stacking
my hands like a pancake here
but essentially you're gonna want to
first post a photo
then post a video then post a
conversation starter
now as your page grows you might realize
wait a second
my audience wants two photos one video
one conversation started but when you're
starting from scratch
i want you to rotate your different
types of content
because you're gonna notice some
patterns you're gonna notice patterns of
people with a photo
when you upload the photo they give it
hearts they give it thumbs ups they give
it those care
signs right if they might even leave a
short comment
when you upload a video you get to have
those that
that time on page which facebook loves
because it means they can
refresh the ads over and over again so
facebook will
keep people watching your content if
they're staying so if
you've got someone on that video for
more than six seconds more than 10
seconds more than 30 seconds
you're gold because facebook's like wow
we can keep
refreshing ads so we're going to put
this video back out on the feet
and live video brings in comments
comments too
is a good thing so comments help tells
facebook this person
loves your post so we're going to show
them more of your posts
next time you create content so photo
video and then the third one i like to
put out there
is conversation starters and
conversation starters are good because
it
helps your audience trust you because
they've had a back and forth dialogue
because anytime you listen to people
they automatically start having this
like connection to you
and you get to foster or build that
connection
with questions that you ask your
audience so conversation starters
and then from conversation starters it
gives facebook those
those long paragraphs where someone says
this is everything i thought about this
and this is why
and then they tag someone so that back
and forth dialogue
facebook eats up now there's i told you
to do photo video
conversation starter and a lot of times
we'll look at the conversation starters
and say
they're not working for my page their
reach is
less than the video so i should do more
videos
less conversation starters and i want
you guys to know
to be careful falling into that trap
because that trap
basically says i'm only looking for my
short-term gains
not my long-term relationship with my
audience
when you do conversation starters
regularly in your feed
what you're going to notice is that
those same people come back
again and again to all of your pieces of
content
and they're going to have other people
seeing that conversation that they're
having with someone else on your feed
and they them having that conversation
means their friends are going to now
trust you more
so when their friends see your ad in
their their feed later
they're already subconsciously going to
remember that they trust you
because they saw you having a
conversation before they won't even be
able to articulate that memory but
they're automatically going to trust you
more and you know this is true
because you see this you see where
so-and-so likes this page would you like
to like it too
like it tells you which one of your
friends like it so facebook knows that
that relationship
between people is important and it's a
social proof factor
when you have those conversations you
get that social proof
that's going to help you grow and
explode so that's content stacking
and you don't wow spend money to make it
happen you can do it like
literally for free okay so three
different types of posts you're hearing
this think marketing three different
type of posts
and you want to be doing those when when
should people be posting
rachel is it every day is it three times
a week is it five times a day
when you're a business owner you know
this because you're running multiple
different
businesses and involved in organizations
when should you post that's a big
question we get all the time
i love that question and the reality is
it's going to depend a lot of people say
how many times should i post
how what which when should i post the
reality is some of your pages mo
a lot of the people here probably should
only be posting once maybe twice a day
because your pages are small so you
should be posting
monday photo tuesday a video thurs
whatever
so but if you are a bigger page so i
actually have
pages that reach millions of people
every
you know whatever so i want those pages
like my one page i had quirky mama i
sold it
but i sold it when i had 2.2 million
they're not gonna be posting one time a
day
they're gonna be posting once an hour
because they had 2.2 million engaged
people on it
they needed to post every hour to make
sure they're they're actually serving
their audience
um they got the same amount of reach if
they posted every hour
as they would if they posted once a day
so you might as well post
each individual post got the same reach
so that meant they got
24 times the reach of a single post
because
facebook is still going to drive that
out to a certain percentage of their
audience each time
and so that meant they had more chances
of having that snowball effect
and that's what i want for all of your
people so it depends on the size of your
page
i would suggest looking at your insights
if you're reaching
say 20 of your audience with every
single post that you put out
you need to be posting more often if
you're reaching
under 10 of your audience and you're
posting
more than two times a day i'm gonna want
you to cut back
because you're posting too many times
that you're not able to
love and effectively serve your audience
so it could be that you're posting four
and now you need to cut back and see if
three does better and maybe you'll have
to cut back to two
and maybe you'll have to cut back even
to one um but if you're
reaching over 20 your audience still has
some
space for growth for for you to put more
out there
and um that's as an average per post so
each
single one of your posts reaching 20 of
your audience which for some of my
students
is the majority of their post reaching
20 wow reaching 20 percent of your
audience organic i mean
think marketing i'm geeking out right
now because these type of numbers to me
are unbelievable when you think about
what's happened with facebook over the
years and
how people really have uh said that you
know facebook really isn't or
an organic play anymore for businesses
and you're debunking that right now
rachel saying
that you have people in your community
and it's not you know
it's not unicorns in your community
that's what we like to call the people
who are just like
major rock stars who just kind of came
in tweaked one thing and
all of a sudden they're your success
students no you have people that you're
helping
from the very beginning right that are
starting from scratch really trying to
reach an audience
and you were telling me a story about
one of your members
i would love for you to share that with
our audience here because i think it it
gives
hope to the idea and i'm even thinking
you know what can we be doing here at
think marketing
to be more dynamic to be reaching more
people on the platform
when you when you hear these numbers it
is it is like making me think
what am i not doing right so i'd love
for you to share that story
you guys you guys are doing a lot of
things right you guys have taught us
with youtube
but like i don't know youtube strategies
and
well i do now because i took your class
which was awesome
but i it's each platform is kind of its
own beast a little bit
sam is a great example she is a paint
supplier like
of all the business like it's for my i
in my mind that's an unusual business
like hi i sell paint like
not i sell like would you like eggshell
baby blue or would you like mint
leaf tea or what i don't know the names
of paint i'm not a paint person
everything in my house is white anyways
she sells
paint and so she created content that
people who are paint crafters
and crafters with paint would go bonkers
for and she talked about things that
paint
people who are paint aficionados
love and next thing you know she now has
a membership where every single month
she sends them a painting project
that was birthed out of this this post
that went viral
and so she got a single post guys to 922
000 people so that's just shy of a
million it was 88 000
shy of a million people like so she
reached more people
than fort worth texas times two i think
or whatever like
anyways a lot of people i don't remember
the exact number of my town now that i'm
thinking about it but anyways
a lot of people more than live in the
state of kansas
um she met a lot of people with this
post
and if she can do it anyone can do it
and she can do it with
paint so it's not like um it's not like
it's
cats or something that's easy to go
viral mind your paint is easy to go
viral when you
find the right paint aficionados who
love paint
but she did it with something that not
is not
broad that everybody loves and she did
it by having a page of just 8 000 people
8 000 people who love paint and love
this topic
and all share that post now it reaches
a million people and it's crazy to see
what's possible for her and she launched
her
membership from it a paid subscription
box that's just amazing it just shows
the power of
knowing who your audience is right we
talk about that all the time having
clarity on your audience
um knowing what the purpose is you know
she really is out there to like help
people like she's not in it for
necessary i mean she probably is
i would assume wanting to provide an
income for her family but she's not
money hungry so it's the purpose behind
what she's doing and then it's putting
the right
positioning in place for what she's
doing
on the platform i think that's just
amazing rachel that you know these type
of things
if um if there's a business owner okay
you're gonna need to credit her just so
that that way people are like well who's
the sam her name is sam hayes and her
page is raggedy something and for some
reason it's leaving my tongue
like the top of my head but you could
look her up on facebook as sam hayes
with raggedy paige and
hopefully it will come up yeah and we'll
make sure to post it in the show notes
of the podcast and if you're watching
this on youtube it'll be down in the
description box below so we'll make sure
that
she's credited so you can go over if
you're a paint person too
uh you can head over and see that but um
there's so many business owners right
now that are having to pivot
you know they're they were you know
offline businesses
or they're seeing the opportunity of
what's happening in the online space
if you had like a tip that you would
love to give to brand
new facebook business owners what
what would be your like biggest tip that
you want to make sure that they know
about
well this is sam she had to pivot
because she had a paint store
and with her current life and all the
stuff that's been happened in the last
couple months
paint stores are stores in general
aren't things that people go to as much
so what she had to do was pivot out of
that business so she pivoted into
um serving our audience hey guys what do
you want
first you had to have an audience so if
this doesn't work if you don't have
anybody there
you don't need a big audience but you do
need some people there that you can talk
to and say
how can i best serve you how can i best
help you continue
to paint even though you're not going to
go to a paint store
how can i best help you how can i best
serve you you need people there
and then you need to talk to those
people and create content that
isn't about you this is what's really
hard because we love to get on we love
to talk about ourselves
we love to say this is what we're gonna
fix for you and this is the benefits of
my product and people don't really care
about the benefits of a product
they care about who they are and what
this product makes them look like right
especially on facebook youtube people
are coming they're typing in a question
right
so they're looking for a solution on
facebook people are looking for
their like they're like little
an escape or like a pat on the back or a
connection right they're not looking for
a solution to a problem so if you come
at it as i'm going to solve your
problems you're going to come across
like their bossy
bossy's older sister or that the it's
not the one that's going to make you
feel warm and fuzzy inside right
so come across it as your your sister
who's
your best buddy who's going to tell you
this is i'm right with you i struggle
with that too
oh really me too i found it oh well i
also tried this
so now it's a conversation instead of me
preaching at you does that make sense so
too often ads preach first she had to
have an audience second she had to have
a conversation with her
her audience instead of preachy content
and then third she had to just
love and serve them and loving and
serving means selling to them so
she one had the audience two made the
content that had a conversation
three she had to step up and say just
because i don't have a paint store that
i can
have you come in and buy paint from or
as much
i mean people could still come to paint
store but you know how it is right now
it's not
traffic is limited um what else how else
can i
serve you because your desire to paint
hasn't gone away
your desire to have pretty walls while
you're stuck in your house all the time
that has
increased not decreased so how can i
love you and serve you
and sell to you don't give yourself an
excuse that i can't do this because of
covin or whatever
this is your chance to step up show up
and do it
so i went wow no thank you so much for
that because i think that is
those three elements are so critical
when you come to any platform and you're
so right when i think about
you know what is facebook and what's the
purpose of facebook and why was it even
created it was to connect
so think marketing podcasts take that
away like what should you be writing
down what action should you take right
now
it's the three pieces of content that
rachel suggested
and it's loving on your people and
connecting with them i love how you just
said i just want to recap this and make
sure that
people are really hearing this you said
that it was about her having a
conversation with her audience
and not being preachy but actually
coming at it from the factor of
i've been there too man i know what it's
like to paint the top
i just had this happen i'm painting and
i put my paint tape up and i let it dry
and i peeled it off and it peeled off an
ugly edge on the top and i'm like man if
i was in a paint group right now
people would be able to relate to me so
i want you to take the advice that
rachel's giving right now
and apply it to your business how could
you be there to serve people on these
platforms remember
we're not on social media to get we're
on social media to give
and so i really hope that isn't that
good i'm writing
it down we are not on social media to
get we're on social media to give oh my
god i love that
hey i wanted to take a pause before we
get into the rest of the interview and
let you know that today's episode is
brought to you
by growth video live 2020. that is our
virtual experience that's coming right
to your living room
this september have you got your tickets
yet did you buy
your ticket to this one of a kind event
that's happening in just a few short
weeks
we are having speakers just like rachel
miller myself
sean cannell and a complete lineup of
social
media rockstars that are going to help
you grow with video
this year if you're a business owner an
entrepreneur a leader
or working in a non-profit video is the
vehicle to get your message out
and we have created this unique
experience just for
you so make sure you get your tickets
for as low as 97
to this year's event at
growethvideolive.com all right let's get
into the rest of the episode
what was the catalyst for you from going
from a
solopreneur doing this as a mom with
kids and like running blogs that are
making money and you're like wow this is
more than my teaching profession
all of that into what was the unlock
what was the catalyst that you were like
oh you know what we can actually make
millions of dollars and hire people and
uh
give massively to charities around the
world like what was that for you was it
a book was it a talk what or was it just
a lifestyle that you currently had
i don't think i've ever been asked that
before so i love that question oh my
word you asked like the best questions
um i think like i had contractors early
on because
once i learned how to do something then
i would find people that would do it
help me with it and do stuff with it but
i hadn't
really saw myself as a business owner
when you're a solopreneur and you have a
couple contractors you're still a solo
printer
you're still running the ship yourself
um which you need to
you can't skip that stage and jump ahead
to having employees
your if you skip that solo printer stage
you will you will fail
um but um you do you can't stay there
forever because you'll burn yourself out
and your business isn't scalable so
anyway so i moved from solopreneur
into with contractors into
now a business i think actually
when you said charities i think that was
the catalyst for me
because you know i don't know if you've
ever noticed if any of your people have
noticed
you get happy in a certain stage of life
so
there's a point where and there's
nothing wrong with this there's
absolutely nothing once but you have all
your needs met
you have everything you could want um
there's no
like severe big giant why in your life
for me um i don't need to work i had my
mortgage i was
paying i paid off our cars our my
business at that time i was able to pay
for my mortgages
um my mortgage i didn't have my husband
was doing still working so
we had savings for like every so we
didn't i didn't have a big
why we weren't travelers we don't we
didn't want more things like
so i had no big why for me to earn more
and what i did and this was like a spur
of the moment thing
i went on a facebook live at an event i
had
been at um it was i don't remember which
event was but i saw
stu mclaren's schools and i don't know
if any of your audience knows me but
i've adopted from ethiopia and we
adopted and it was a
tough situation i felt i met both my
children's birth parents and i
wanted to fix what had happened in the
sense
my children shouldn't have been adopted
because
their community should have supported
those moms
so that this was never an option for
them because they both
different circumstances they wanted
their kids but they couldn't and the
community wasn't letting them it was
just
so they felt pressure like it just
wasn't it wasn't
it hurt does that make sense it does
so i wanted to stop birth moms from
being put in that circumstance again
and so i saw um the chance
and i didn't want to give money to an
orphanage because that keeps kids in an
orphanage it supports that
i didn't want to give money to the moms
because next thing you know they're
going to be making babies so that again
money so it's like all of these like
well what if this whatever this
what is a way that you can completely
change a community
from the ground up where that's they see
the world there where that's not they
wouldn't do this to their women
um and so i um
saw stu mclaren build a school and i was
like
i'm going to build a school the whole
school so he's like well why don't you
build a classroom i'm like no i'm not
going to build a classroom
that's for other people i don't have any
money i mean i have money but i didn't
have money for a 135
000 school um but i committed publicly
to building an entire school so suddenly
i had a big
why and suddenly i had to make money
because i had to do something and i had
a big calling that suddenly
and a big bill and it wasn't about me
and so i was still i still
felt comfortable growing my business
because it wasn't about me
and there's like this money issue you
have as you're escaping out of that
solopreneur you're kind of like oh i
shouldn't make that much money i'm
feeling guilty about making as much
money
and for me kind of pushing that onto the
school i didn't even realize that that's
what i was doing
um allowed me to have the freedom to
scale and i suddenly had
a duty to hire employees because there
was no way i was going to have a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars in profit
in under 10 months time in profit that i
could give to the school
if i didn't have this whole structure
behind me and
we did it and i mean i still want to
like i was supposed to be actually
i'm going to start crying i was supposed
to be in ethiopia right now and not
either in kenya right now to see the
school
um right now like i was supposed to be
in their country right now
but yeah
wow that is i didn't mean to go like on
it no
no thank you so much rachel for sharing
that i think
um that that right there is
why we're when we say we want to reach
10 000 people it's not
it's so that that type of impact can
happen you know and it's when you really
grasp that why i love how you said you
know there is a point
where your needs are kind of met and and
it's like what's the next
thing what's you know because again i
know a lot of people in our community
and in your community you know it's not
about the rolling in the bins and flying
in the private jet i'm like
i i love my kids but i i kind of want to
vacation alone
you know it's not and we're not though
and and nothing against that but
when you can tie what you're doing in
business
to a greater good in the world that's
like
what you just said lean in because hear
this rachel said it felt like a
duty to scale her business so that she
could
impact other people and i'm just i just
want to honor you
so much for being an entrepreneur that
goes beyond
yourself and really sees that this is a
way that we can connect and we can give
and we can serve to others
um around the world so thank you so much
for sharing that beautiful story
yeah i'm super super grateful i think it
i think building the school almost built
me more than
even the school but i do appreciate the
fact that there are moms now that won't
have to
make desperate choices rachel thank you
so much for
being on today where can people connect
with you where do you love to hang out
obviously facebook
but uh where can they go deeper if
they're interested in the products and
services you offer
well we actually have a four dollar
product right now so it's like a cup of
coffee
and it writes your content for you so
you can
get photo ideas video ideas and all the
conversation starters you could ever
need
at a copy and paste so you just copy
them fill in the blanks and then
paste them on your social media in
seconds and it's cheaper than a cup of
coffee
well if you get a venti it's cheaper
than a venti
i get the cheapo cups but whatever i
love that
where can they where can they go if
they're listening and they're driving
right now where would they go for that
postdeck dot io well i hope that
interview with rachel brought value to
you
and allowed you to see that organic
traffic is not dead
on the facebook platform like i said
with over 1.6 billion
active users b with a b your audience is
there
it's just about the content you're
putting on the platform so to break
through
make sure you're asking these two
questions am i putting content that
serves my audience
or does it serve me is this engaging
content
do people want to share it do people
want to comment on it do people want to
be
social on this social media platform and
think about those things
every time you go to post on facebook
now i'm excited because
rachel will be diving more into this
topic on facebook organic reach
at grow with video live this year yep
it's happening in just a few short weeks
and i cannot
wait to bring this virtual experience
right to you
you know it was important to us that
through everything we're going with
that's happening right now
the grow with video live was still a
staple of our year
why because it's more critical now than
ever to be
learning and growing and thinking of
ways that we can
rethink our businesses it's critical
that we learn how to use
these video platforms to be able to
reach the people we need to
with the message that matters most and
it grows video live
we take it to heart to make sure that
we're not only giving you the strategies
we're helping you with the mindset but
we're bringing together community
we have worked extra hard this year to
make sure that while we may be
distanced from each other physically
that we are together
when we're at this conference so people
from around the world will be joining us
people just like you
and you can connect with them at this
conference so make sure to get your
ticket today
at growethvideolive.com we have tickets
as low as 97
for you to experience this three-day
fully packed conference
of not only again the strategies to move
yourself forward the mindset to get you
right in the right mind to move your
business forward
but also so that you can connect with
other people just like you because i
know from doing this for over a decade
that it can feel lonely it can feel
isolating and we want you to connect
with the right people
and make the right connections for
what's next in your business so make
sure to get your tickets
at growethvideolive.com and join us in
september
all right it is time for the review of
the day did you know you can leave a
review
over on apple itunes you can go over
there and rate and review this podcast
it helps us so much it triggers to apple
that hey i like listening to this
and other people might too so when you
leave a review you might be featured on
the podcast and today's review comes
from john weiner he said think media is
the
goat if you know anything about video
marketing
you know think media they have given me
literally everything i need to grow a
youtube channel
this is a sweet cherry on top you won't
regret anything you listen to here and
ps
i quit my full-time job because i
believe in this stuff
well john thank you so much for leaving
that review and again remember
at think media our mission is to help
ten thousand people go
full time using the power of video doing
what they love and making a difference
in the world
and john is one of those ten thousand
are you going to be one of the ten
thousand
let us know on the podcast review over
on apple
well thank you so much for listening to
this episode we'd love to hear from you
in the community you can connect with us
on social media
everywhere mine is at miss heather
torres you can connect with sean at sean
cannell
and i want you to take action i want you
to take what you've learned here
all about facebook all about how you can
grow organically
and start applying it now thanks for
listening and we'll catch you in the
next episode